oh I miss you too baby but don't worry
we can be together now forever oh yeah I
miss you Sharky yeah poof oh is that my
daughter hey Stacy come over here I want
to pet you humans like that being petted
come back here ah fine I'm gonna go see
my son no one who actually respects me
but suspiciously looks a lot like the
mailman I'm gonna lose my Wow Beth
you're gonna die tonight you and your
taut chest in your lovely what you look
good sailor smack poof
uh-huh do you mind if I dance while we
talk just a little bit of a Samba huh
hey buddy nice ass Wow oh it's a
heartwarming story love it affected me
okay
I'm better now sweet soul and darkness
does look pretty normal for humans I
think I just threw that into my eyeballs
maybe I got a smash you open in the keys
inside you know I'd never hurt you I
would never hurt you my little biscuit
Bloody Mary trick in the mirror you
stretching yawn deciding now is the best
time did they